all right hi everybody thanks for coming
everyone excited to be here for October
yeah yeah yeah it's October yes all
right well good to have everyone here uh
we're at our new host this month NYU so
everyone Round of Applause for NYU thank
you for hosting
[Applause]
us one of the conditions we had for
being here is that we insisted the NYU
person speak to put him on the line so
uh that's actually she's actually
filling we had a bit of a schedule shift
from last month we had to move forward
to speak we had to move forward another
speaker so he should have been speaking
in November which is why he's just
finishing up his slides now so you know
thank you very much for filling in for
us and for arranging this beautiful
space uh so first up we always ask to
get this meet up is anyone hiring who's
hiring fewer people post pandemic are
hiring all right so if no one is hiring
in the room people who are here
virtually if you're hiring go to the NY
haar slack you can find it by going to
Nyack car.org and clicking the little
hashtag at the top and you'll be able to
go find the slack and go to the job
postings Channel and let people know
about the job you have great since no
one is hiring no one wants to give
someone a job let me go to my other
announcements they
are all right the pizza the pizza this
month came from Benz of Soho so let us
know what you think go to bit. leple
that's bitly Pizza pole and rate the
pizza it's a scale essentially from 1 to
5 we have we we they're categorical but
it's a ordered scale let us know how the
pizza is for those of you that have not
been here before you know that we don't
know that we've been collecting these
data for 12 years or something at least
10 years no definitely more than 10
years so we want to keep that going so
if you're in the room and you ate pizza
go to bitly pull your phones I see
everyone just sitting there staring pull
your phones go to the website and vote
the pizza I see Paul's already doing it
thank you Paul every once you vote on
the pizza let us know what you think
those of you that are attending
virtually hopefully you have pizza
wherever you are but if you didn't have
pizza hopefully you had some good food
or snack or beverage that you enjoy let
us know in the in the chat speaking of
chat there are two ways you can chat
with us and this goes to people in the
room too go to the NY hackr there's a
channel called monthly Meetup chat or go
on the YouTube live stream and chat
right in there let us know where you're
eating what you're what you're eating if
you're eating anything at all if you're
not let us know what you're em bibing or
just let us know you're live so everyone
in the room hope you enjoy the
pizza next week we have our annual R in
government conference there's a two-day
conference plus the day of workshops
held down at Georgetown University in
Washington DC it's about our and friends
because there's an open conference just
like our meetup group we have R python
Julia SQL go anything about data
anything that's open it's a conference
next week if you want to learn more you
go to rats. it takes place Wednesday
through Friday um if you want a discount
code because your members of this group
this goes with people in the room and
virtual CU it's both inperson and
virtual you could use code NY hackr for
for a 20% discount at
rats. and we will be giving away to this
room this is the last giveaways we're
doing before the conference because it's
next week we're going to give away one
ticket to someone in this room and one
ticket to someone attending virtually
and you can redeem those tickets for
either a virtual or in person ticket
depending where you are so hope people
will attend that have a good time we've
been putting on this conference I think
this is the sixth year now and it's
really it's a really good time to learn
about the ours use in both not just both
ours use in federal local state county
and international governments and for
the public sector at various NOS it's
going to be a very fun
time then apparently everything I just
had on my list just
disappeared okay that's
disconcerting so oh here it is great all
right our next Meetup will be back in
NYU not in this room in a different room
in plus Hall is that nearby yes it's
right down the street from here our next
meet up will be November
14th put that in your calendars but
remember I said we had to shuffle the
speakers around that October September
speaker cancel we to move October to
September November to October we need a
speaker we have the date we have the
venue we need a speaker if no one
volunteers by next week I will volunteer
someone all right someone in this room
maybe I will point at you and say you're
speaking all right that's the way this
works sometimes so November 14th at myyu
but we still need a speaker so please
help us out if you don't want to speak
find someone who does want to speak when
you came in the back of them there's a
bunch of hex stickers grab some more hex
stickers take them home put put them on
your belongings enjoy the hex
stickers for people in the room we will
do Q&A after we do the ticket giveaway
for people not in the room if you ask
questions on either the slack or on
YouTube I will coate those and ask those
questions for you afterwards okay so in
the room you can ask questions
yourself not in the room we will um we
will coate them for you all right so
with that hope everyone's having a great
time and is ready for our speaker I want
to have a big round of Applause for
doing this a month early he was
literally finishing the slides a few
minutes ago everyone please welcome
George thanks so much everybody for
being here uh for those of you who
listen to me speak at the New York City
Art conference this will be a little bit
of refresher but diving a little bit
deeper um and so today I'm talking about
bart it's a short for basing added
regression trees it's a powerful machine
learning model it has applications for
prediction and also inference problems
and I'm going to be giving some
background on what BART is how does it
work why would you be interested in it
and then spend a lot of time in how do
we actually use it like if you're a
practitioner if you're out in the world
and you want to try to apply this to
your work how do you get started and so
we're going to be taking a broad survey
of what you can do with Bart and I'm
going to my goal for today is to try to
introduce you guys to some areas where
you can explore
deeper so I want to think of an example
of the hypers shoe so a sporting company
has just released a new high performance
shoe and they're going to call it the
hypers shoe and they're going to
claim that maybe there's a relationship
of some sort between the shoe and how
fast you can run a marathon so let's say
given some data on Runners say we have a
bunch of data from a prior year in the
Boston Marathon maybe some runners wear
the shoes some Runners don't we know
they're qualifying times for the
marathon can we predict this year's
marathon time using that
data and so we have some example we've
got prior race as a predictor we've got
this variable Z which is just denoting
are you wearing the hypers shoe or are
you not and we have our outcome which is
how many minutes did it take you to run
the Boston
Marathon and if we look at our data it
looks a little
nonlinear now there's a bunch of tools
we have in our disposal to handle
nonlinear cases and we're going to walk
through some of the options that we'd
have if we wanted to just make
predictions right now we're really not
making any inferences we're just trying
trying to predict the outcome running
time so a good starting point is we
could fit a linear aggression now I've
fit a linear regression on the left side
of the screen and the right side of the
screen and our rmse our root mean
squared error is about 17 for our
training data and it's also about 17 for
our testing data and so what this means
is linear aggression is performing about
the same on an out of sample data set as
an insample data set um in the machine
learning literature we'd say that it is
higher in bias and lower in variance we
say it's higher in bias because our
predictions aren't that good we could
probably do a little bit better an rmsc
of 17 seems pretty high we're not really
predicting each runner's time
particularly well but the good news of
using this model is our predictions are
at least not degrading when we try to
predict a future data we haven't
seen now another approach is we could do
What's called the regression tree now
this is something that people are a
little bit less familiar with compared
to linear regression and so I'm going to
spend some time on the intuitions behind
a regression tree you can think of
regression trees as an extension of
analysis of variance if you're familiar
with that model um we've heard of anovas
before and the idea with an anova is
we're just trying to see how much
variance is explained conditional on
some groups usually these are
categorical variables so we can
calculate the mean uh sum of squares
within versus sum of squares between for
uh a call back to intro stats um so the
idea of a regression tree is we have a
continuous variable and if we could just
make one cut in our continuous variable
where do we want to draw the line to
explain the most variance in our outcome
and so if we limit our regression tree
just making one cut the best cut we can
make is somewhere between a qualifying
time of 250 minutes and a qualifying
time of 300 minutes now to the left of
that cut we're just going to take the
mean the average of all the data points
and to the right of the cut we're just
going to take the mean of all the data
points and that's going to be a
prediction now we wouldn't expect this
to predict very well we can just
visually see that it's not fitting the
data particularly good but we can keep
making Cuts we can make multiple cuts
and keep growing so now um it may be a
little small I hope people can see that
um so now on the training data set RS
rmse is around 20 so we're we're still
doing worse than linear regression and
our test set is around 21 so we're still
not making a lot of
progress but now we have kind of four
groupings of means we've made more Cuts
along um along in this case qualifying
time one of our predictors and we're
just taking means within each of these
Cuts now the thing about regression
trees is we don't have to stop nothing
stopping us from making more and more
and more and more cuts and the more and
more and more Cuts we make the better
we're going to get get at predicting our
in Sample data now sometimes this can
lead to making better predictions out of
sample but there's going to be a point
where maybe things start turning
around so if we make more and more and
more Cuts our ins sample predictions for
rmsc now go down to 12 so now we're
outperforming linear aggression so it's
it's pretty easy to model this data
better when we don't assume a linear
pattern um and as we can see the data is
not particularly linear so this
shouldn't be surprising now in this case
our test set starts jumping up a little
bit more as we saw earlier the kind of
gap between training and test was was
pretty small now it's starting to get a
little bit larger so in the machine
learning world this would be What's
called the bias variance tradeoff so we
can start modeling the data we see much
much much better but at some point we're
going to start overfitting that data and
we're going to start chasing noise we're
just going to start chasing patterns
that actually aren't there and that's
not going to help us make predictions
for data we haven't seen and most of the
time in sports analytics or business or
science we're not interested in just the
data we have but also the data we
haven't seen yet and so that's not going
to help us now in this example it's
still not bad a 13 RMC we can live with
that it's only a small jump we went from
kind of an rmse of 12 in Sample to an
rmsse of 13 out of samples so that's a
that's a still not too bad but what if
we kept going now we could imagine we go
and go and go and go till we basically
cut for every single data point and
we're just our prediction is our
observation now that's going to be
really problematic for us so we need
some type of strategy to keep getting
more and more flexible to keep kind of
fitting the data more more nonlinearly
but also guarding against overfitting
and by overfitting this kind of gap
between our ability to predict on the
data we actually have and data that our
model hasn't seen
yet now one of the most popular tools
for this challenge is it's called
gradient boosted regression trees so
gradient boosted regression trees take
the idea of a single regression tree and
build a bunch of them together so what
if we have a bunch of really really
small regression trees so the idea is
well if just one tiny tree boosts
another tree and then that boosts
another tree we can get really flexible
nonlinear predictions but still against
overfitting now how do we actually keep
the trees small and the examples I just
walked through you saw that I could
control how many Cuts we're making now
those are all tunable parameters in
these algorithms the question is what do
we set them to well usually we rely on
things like cross validation where we
just try a bunch of options out and see
which ones work the best usually you
hold some chunk of your data out you fit
your model on the data you've decided to
keep and then see how it perform on the
subset that you've held out this is very
very common I'm sure it's not surprising
to a lot of people in those rooms in
this in this room um and so if we add
together each of these small regression
trees our predictions are going to be
more flexible and we're keeping them as
small by kind of keeping the amount of
cuts limited and we're picking that
limit through uh cross validation
there's also other important parameters
called a learning rate it's just a small
number we're going to multiply to each
of the predictions to kind of shrink it
a little bit again a tunable parameter
parameter in the case of gradient
boosted trees these are the two most
important parameters that tend to be um
focused on during cross
validation okay so this is all very
abstract let's think about what's
actually going on so the first step of a
gradient boosted regression tree is
we're just going to start with the mean
if we don't have any other prediction
just the average of our outcome wise
probably the best we can do so we're
just going to start there and then we're
going to fit a really small regression
tree and we're going to take the
residual from the mean and we're going
to fit the regression Tree on that so we
have our prediction the mean we
basically say well how far away is each
data point from the mean and we're going
to fit a regression Tree on that and
we're keep that regression tree really
small and then we're going to take the
residuals between that mini regression
tree and the remaining data and we're
going to fit a regression Tree on
that and every step we're kind of
multiplying by the shrinkage parameter
and it's it's keeping the trees from
learning too
fast now if you didn't have this
shrinking this shrinkage parameter what
would actually happen is after like two
or three trees we' be overfitting again
and it's going to really prevent us from
moving too fast and really slowly we're
going to get more and more and more
flexible and we're going to keep growing
slowly and slowly and slowly and each
step we're getting a little bit smoother
a little bit smoother this is after 10
trees and usually we have a lot of these
really small trees when I say a lot it's
not just one or two usually it's in the
hundreds like 100 125 those are some
good ballpark estimates sometimes we'll
go down to 75 depending on how your data
is
structured and we could keep fitting and
fitting and fitting and ultimately we'll
have some final model we'll use now
interestingly enough the rcode to
produce these models is uh actually
pretty pretty not um not too complex you
can do in about 10 lines um if you ever
want to fit your own gradient boosted
tree but if we if we fit it to our
running data we see now that we're
modeling things much more flexibly so in
the in Sample we're still at 11 and in
the out of sample we're at 12.8 so we're
doing better than we were with some of
the regression trees and the linear
regression from earlier um but we're
managing the overfitting a little bit
more effectively and we can see our our
model on these data points is is hugging
the data much much tighter than our
aggression tree was so now we're
modeling things much more flexibly
without trying to just make a cut for
each dat a point and predict yourself
cuz that would it's not going to help us
it's not going to do well when we're
interested in things that we haven't
seen yet now the question today is uh
can we do better than this is there
something else we can do um and some of
the challenges with this approach is
well we have to do a lot of cross
validation and cross validation takes a
lot of time especially on big data sets
you could in theory expand the grid
forever now there's some optimization
techniques you can use to try make
better guesses but at the end of the day
you're going to have to do a lot of
cross validation and also we're just
left with a single prediction we don't
really know how confident our model is
in those predictions it's just kind of
giving us a number and we're taking it
at face value so it would be convenient
if we could use a flexible method like
gradient boosted regression trees but
also had some more information about
well how confident are we in this
runner's time we can get a prediction
that maybe some Runner runs
170 minutes
but is it
within 165 and 180 or is it maybe within
like 100
200 what's the range that we're looking
at and so these challenges are what BART
can can answer um so what is Bart it's
short for basing and additive regression
trees and it's a flexible non-parametric
model and the whole idea is we're just
trying to estimate some unknown function
f f is this function that we believe is
is
um the response of Y and we're going to
try to see what that looks like now
we're going to make some assumptions
we're going to make an assumption that
the error is normally
distributed which most statistical
models have this baked in um that's
actually not a particularly strong
assumption compared to all the other
tools that we use the difference between
Bart and something like like gradient
boosted regression trees is to handle
the regularization which basically just
means the shrinkage to prevent us from
overfitting instead of using cross
validation we're going to use basian
priors and in the function right here
these G terms that's reflecting the
regularization properties of the
prior so each regression tree gives a
prediction they're called terminal nodes
or leavs in kind of the regression tree
literature so for each tree we have a
series of predictions M now we can
follow an individual down the tree and
it's going to give us their prediction
it's the same thing we saw earlier when
I talked about making those cuts we just
see well if we just have one cut what
side of the cut are you on and then
depending on what side you're on your
predictions just the mean of that group
and that's what we mean by these T and M
terms so for each tree we're going to
follow it down the sequences of cuts and
then just see which group you're part of
and that's going to be your prediction
now just like gradient boosted machine
we're going to add all these terms up so
we're going to have a bunch of small
trees that make teeny tiny predictions
and at the end of our process we're just
going to sum it all up and that's our
prediction for an individual now instead
of using explicit learning rate this G
term which is really a combination of a
few things is going to prevent our
predictions from getting too excited
getting carried
away so how does this actually work um
well the priors are really doing a lot
of the work in
um now we have uh a system in which
trees are actually going to be proposed
and they're going to be accepted or
rejected this is different than what GBM
is doing in GBM it's just fitting trees
now what does it mean to propose or
accept a tree it it seems kind of nuts
so the idea is well we start
with something like the mean and we
could imagine fitting a tree that is
better than the mean and so we're going
to use a kind of predetermined subset of
rules rules and the algorithm is going
to randomly pick one and say you know
what if what if we added a split here
and it's going to say well how would
this split do compared to what we had
before and with some probability that's
either going to be accepted or rejected
and it's going to be done so in such a
way that we're gradually going to favor
trees that improve the
fit and this is how we kind of trade out
traditional hyperparameters for things
like uh like for tree depth and learning
rate for for basy and prior
um now let's think a little bit more
about the beliefs we might have for
regression Trea for those of you who are
kind of from a traditional have heard
about traditional Bas and statistics
this seems kind of nuts people are used
to picking priors in like a regression
coefficient like you have some idea
about a reasonable range for a
coefficient to be and so you put some
probability distribution on that
coefficient and it's going to calibrate
um and kind of restrict how carried away
your aggression can get get so how does
this work with regression trees well we
actually have some pretty concrete
beliefs about how regression trees
should be
behaving now we actually know that we
should be pretty skeptical about
predictions that are really far away
from the general
mean like we said if we didn't have any
other information the best we could do
is the average so we should be pretty
wary of things that are really really
extreme that could be a sign that we're
starting to
overfit we also know that trees should
be pretty small
this is the whole mechanism of how
gradient boosted machines works by
keeping each tree small or preventing
overfitting so we already have a belief
that they're supposed to be relatively
constrained this is not shocking at
all and we also think that our model
should outperform linear aggression
we're not making any traditional
parametric assumptions in a shape of f f
could be whatever shape it wants to be
it could be a step function it could be
a curve and we're thinking that we can
model that and that we can represent
that function pretty well certainly
better than a straight line can and so
these are the ideas that we just need to
break into
priors now how does this actually work
well the critiques and one of the
challenges of basan Statistics is how do
we pick the priors um sometimes uh in
some Journal articles for example
referees may be um wary of well did you
get the result because you just picked a
prior and maybe the prior is is playing
an outside influence over result and
what would have happened without the
priors and and there's this idea that
our priors are kind of representing our
subjective relief beliefs now all those
things certainly can happen but there's
other ways to think about setting priors
and if the priors have such a big role
in the process here how are we choosing
them in a principled
way so it turns out with what we're
doing with Bart the priors are actually
calibrated from the data largely which
is really helped ful for us it means you
guys can use Bart without a strong
knowledge of setting basian priors um
and one of the convenient features of
this algorithm is the default priors are
going to work remarkably well so much so
we're using Bart with the default is
going to perform as well or if not
better than existing machine learning
methods when they've been tuned
thoroughly so we can kind of use it off
the box and get really or out of the box
I should say and get really really
strong
performance and that's a big Advantage
because we can maybe get a good estimate
right off right away of how good our
model we're doing without spending hours
or weeks that we'd be doing a massive
grid search we don't have to worry about
setting up a basing optimization weight
a hypertune things we can just perform
pretty well right out of the gate now
there's for this is all for continuous
outcomes um you can use BART to make
predictions about binary outcomes things
get a little bit uh um trickier there
where you'll have to do some more work
maybe
uh cross validating a specific prior um
which we'll talk about in a little bit
but for for continuous variables the
calibration is going to give you a
really good answer right away
fortunately for us what we're going to
be talking about later on too in the
implementation even for binary cases
there's some tricks that are already
built into the package that's going to
help you get a good answer without
having to know a whole lot about
probability distributions or about
setting basing priors in general so this
algorithm is a little bit less
intimidating than um say using a basian
regression where you explicitly need to
use distributions and have a lot of
knowledge about um how to specify
thoughts that you have and beliefs into
the actual estimation process whereas
here we're just using the data we
already have to kind of enforce our
beliefs that we already know about
regression trees and these beliefs are
going to be the same in essentially
every problem we have in the
sociomedical Sciences we know that
really really deep trees are going to
overfit it's it's a process of of how
the trees
work so there's three priors the first
and arguably the one that's doing the
most work for us is the prior on me
sometimes this is called the prior on
the
means now when we actually fit these
things under the hood at the beginning
of the process it's going to rescale
your data so it's going to take your
outcome and say okay we're going to
apply transformation and kind of make it
so everything's between negative .5 and5
and set the mean to zero and this is
going to be really convenient it's going
to help us kind of calibrate our priors
without the user having to put in a lot
of work and we're also know that for
each kind of terminal node which is just
a fancy way of saying for each of our
predictions we want mean to be
distributed or the me the mean to be
distributed normally um at zero with uh
a standard deviation of Sigma
squar um or with variance Sigma Square I
should say and so for each individual
well it's just a sum across all these
little terminal nodes and so we can
apply some knowledge about this to
shrink in extreme cases the idea is to
set this this mu prior so that 95% of
our values fall within maybe ne5 and 0.5
we know that things shouldn't be too
extreme we don't want things getting too
too far away from the mean um and so if
we use this kind of knowledge that we
have it's going to give us um it's going
to make this probabilistic statement
true and so the default value in here is
a k value of two this is called K this
kind of PRI on the means now like I said
it's going to work really really really
well out of the box and if you're doing
binary predictions the package you're
going to use has a lot of tools built in
so it's also going to work really really
well out of the box still could be a
good idea to maybe do some cross
validation but you're going to be
starting from a strong
position and like I said the idea here
is we're really going to keep our our
nodes from getting to two extreme each
of these groups it's going to be kind of
range in so if it starts to give
predictions Way Beyond this5 it's a sign
that the regression trees are getting a
little bit too sensitive and it's going
to squeeze things back
in again the big big takeaway from this
slide you don't need to understand all
the math or all the kind of baked in
probability assumptions it's just we
want things to be generally closer to
the mean and extreme things are going to
get squeezed back in we can also set a
prior on tree depth so we can use um a
distribution
and it's going to kind of determine How
likely we are to propose different trees
so as I said we're going to be kind of
proposing trees and they're going to be
accepted or rejected well what's the
depth of these trees going to be we can
kind of reain that in and as I said we
want to keep our trees relatively small
remember the higher the depth it means
the more Cuts we're making depth is
another way of saying just make
additional Cuts so we can say well we we
know we should probably have at least
like one cut or two cuts
so maybe you want a high concentration
around two
and this number um so I should also say
Bart was initially invented by Chipman
George and mccullock uh there were three
um statisticians uh that develop the
actual algorithm and they explored a lot
of these different combinations and set
on on this number and it worked really
well for them in practice and so the
idea is well we're saying it's really
likely to have depths of around two or
three and less likely to get into four
or five and also less likely to be one
we're going to need some depth but once
we get Beyond this kind of threep point
it can get carried away pretty quickly
now the important thing to know though
is if it turns out that for whatever
problem we're modeling maybe we need
deeper
trees if the data demands it the trees
will get deep enough so in the initial
paper about bart they explore a bunch of
these trees and they actually recorded a
depth of 17 on one of them so it can get
pulled deeper and deeper and deeper if
if uh proposals that add depth continue
to be accepted
so the prior isn't a hard cut off it's
it'll allow us to still move flexibly
it's just going to need to see a strong
signal before it gets too
excited so the prior on means is about
pulling predictions inward the prior on
trees is about keeping our trees nice
and shallow again all this stuff's
encoded in the default I'm just more of
putting it here to give some context on
how we're going to be making these good
predictions and how and the mechanisms
that are in place that's maybe making it
less necessary to cross validate these
parameters like I said sometimes cross
validating that mean parameter K can be
helpful generally in practice um I've
had a lot of work with this algorithm
usually I've not looked at um ever cross
validating the priors on the
trees and our last PRI is going to be
this prior on Sigma and we had that last
kind of belief that we really think we
should be doing better than a linear
regression and so at the beginning of
our of our process we're just going to
fit an OS ordinar Le squared regression
and we're going to see how well we're
going to do now a conservative it's
going to give us a conservative
Benchmark of saying well like even if uh
even if it really was like we're only
doing as good as regression how good is
that going to be and we think that we
should have about a 90% probability that
our Sigma is going to be smaller than
from OS and so we can go that into the
prior and it's going to help us kind of
determine um this last little piece of
the puzzle
again this is one where the
default I would feel very confident
using most of the tuning that happens in
these models is all on that
mean so the whole process kind of like
ing gradient boosted trees we're going
to start with the mean and we're going
to propose a variety of trees maybe it's
we're going to grow a new tree or we're
going to prune a tree or we're gonna
flip a tree uh we're goingon to add a
split we're gonna we're going to change
these trees around and there is uh a
pre-specified number of trees we're
going to go usually it's about 75 and
that's kind of hardcoded in you can add
more trees if You' like um usually the
range is somewhere between maybe 75 and
up to 200 um but generally in my work I
ually use around 75 and these trees are
going to be accepted or they're going to
be rejected so we'll propose a new split
and there's some probabilistic method in
the algorithm that's going to determine
if that split is accepted or not and
we're going to be favoring acceptances
trees that improve our fit and we're
going to do this again and again and
again and again we're actually going to
do this thousands of times and we're
going to throw out a bunch of the times
from the beginning it's called the
Burnin phase and cuz at first our
proposals are probably not going to be
great um there's some Randomness here
and we kind of need the algorithm to
warm up for a little bit so after a
sufficient warmup
period we have a whole bunch of runs
through this algorithm like I said
there's about 75 trees so we have 75
trees and it's going to f it's going to
propose more treats and it's going to
keep making proposals and it's going to
propose and propose and propose and
these are called iterations and so after
thousands of iterations we believe that
we have a pretty good estimate of f now
one fact about B that's a little bit
different than GBM and gbn The Ordering
of the trees is really important because
each tree is essentially predicting on
leftover from the last tree so in Bart
all the trees are actually exchangeable
you could move around the order and get
the same result and that's because we
ran it so many times for these
iterations and each proposed tree is
kind of conditional on all the other
trees that came before it so because
we've already conditioned on all of the
prior trees we can move around the
ordering of the trees and it's not going
to change our predictions from the
sum now this was a very very long
warm-up to get to well how did we
actually
do so with a Bart model our in Sample
rmse is going to be around
11.2 which is pretty good we've seen
some other in Sample predictions that
have been lower but when we look at how
they perform on out of sample data it
gets much worse I think regression trees
you can get them to really overfit and
so they can fit really really good in
fact they can fit perfectly if they
continue to make more and more and more
in cuts and the problem is what happens
when you see out of sample
data now here our jump when we go from
our training set to our testing set is
the smallest we've seen so far and to
date this is the best prediction we have
so our rmsse here is about 12.2 and so
we're making
better predictions than gvm better
predictions than all the things before
us now the classic issue with using
these simulated examples and I simulated
this data myself as well did you just
make up some data that kind of fit your
use case um and so there's been some
work um on comparing BART to other
existing
algorithms um oh and actually we're
going to get to that work in a second I
also made a little bit of a
generalization so when I showed this we
have this nice little prediction line
Bart's actually making distributional
predictions
so we're making a prediction a
probability distribution for each point
so we can draw the line that is the
average or we can also think about well
what is the distribution of our
predictions for each given point and
this is going to be really really
convenient because sometimes we don't
just care about the point prediction we
want to know how confident our model is
in that prediction your opinions about a
model may be different if you say well
we're predicting a say a time of
150 now is that prediction between maybe
145 and 155 or is it between 100 and 300
those things should mean very very
different things to when you're working
as an applied modeler we prefer models
that are probably a little bit more
confident in their predictions now
there's other ways you could get these
types of results using traditional
machine learning methods you could um
use various resampling techniques like
the bootstrap or the inferential jack
knife all those things can get at
similar issues but the problem is that's
going to be incredibly computationally
demanding just spits this out as a
process of estimation so we have this
built into how the algorithm is actually
making predictions and we can use this
not just for predictions but it's also
going to make it's also going to be
really convenient if we want to use
machine learning models for inference
problems now as I saw and this picture
got cut off a little bit um it's
possible that maybe I overfit BART to uh
the ones who developed Bart they tested
out the algorithm over 42 data sets and
uh 800 train test splits and they looked
at Bart without cross validation at all
and with some cross validation to things
like that prior on the means and so what
we see and they compared it to other top
performing algorithms of the time
boosting is just a term for uh gradient
boosted machines um they use neural
networks random
forests and um I believe uh
um one other algorithm got cut off I
think think it is um support Vector
machines also but so what we see is when
you use Bart out of the box Bart default
it's
performing as well if not just a little
bit better than the existing models and
when we cross validate Bart that
prediction gets even better so across a
wide variety of data sets we're seeing
really really good performance even
without spending a lot of time cross
validating and I should say all the
competitor models were fully cross
validated so we're kind of giving them
the most favorable treatment and just
pulling Bart straight out of the
box now all of this seems a little bit
abstract how do we actually use the
thing so I'm going to be talking about
what a lot of my work is about which is
using the darts family of packages to
actually address apply problems now what
are these problems sometimes are
interest prediction problems sometimes
are interested in inference problems and
the darts family of packages it's really
three packages and the debart package is
kind of at the heart of it is going to
help answer each of these challenges now
there's um there's definitely other
approaches in no way do I want to say
that Bart is the only solution but it is
a tool that you can use in your toolbox
and one that has a lot of advantages in
my opinion um and I also want to give
credit to uh my colleague Vince Dory
Vince Dory was the developer of the
darts package a lot of my work is on um
applying the darts package and and its
kind of other um its family of packages
to work in causal inference um so a lot
of my work is seeing how these things
perform in the causal inference space um
but this was developed by Vince Dory and
a lot of um a lot of his work um has
been uh
cited so how do we actually fit one of
these models now the inspiration for
this talk is I've given talks about bart
in the past and it's this kind of
highlevel version where I'm just talking
about oh here's how the algorithm Works
here's how it performs pretty well um
but how do you actually use the thing
and it turns out uh I had a lot of
conversations with people after some of
these talks how to actually use the
thing can be a little bit confusing um
there's documentation out there but it
can be very very dense it can be hard to
read and there's a lot of things that
may not make sense if you're not steeped
deep in the space like first of all um
the first step is downloading the
package so you can download the darts
package from cran or you can install it
from uh GitHub directly for the most
recent development version so if you
want to fit a Bart model here's
confusing Point number one there is a
fun called Bart and there is a function
called Bart 2 you want to use Bart
2 uh Bart is the initial kind of um
implementation that uh has a lot of the
defaults used by Chipman geordan
mccullock Bart 2 um is this kind of
expanded version that has um some more
in-depth defaults worked into it so for
example um if you fit Bart 2 with A
continuous outcome it's default prior on
the means it's going to be set to two
and that's that value that we know is
working pretty well out of the box means
we expect 95% of our cases to be within
one standard deviation of the mean or
sorry within two standard deviations of
the main um within two standard
deviations of the main now as I
referenced earlier binary predictions
get a little bit harder now Bart 2 has a
very very uh sophisticated kind of guess
at what K should be um binary outcomes
you want to tune k a little bit um now B
two when you have a binary outcome it's
going to know it's a binary outcome it
checks if it's binary or not and it's
going to use this kind of built-in hyper
prior um it's not a set value of K it's
going to estimate a good value of K and
so it's going to change k for you for
binary variables so you can still use it
out of the box um if you're really
trying to get maximum performance I
would cross validate k um but out of the
box it's still going to perform pretty
well for binary or continuous variables
um but the original Bart Bart without
the two uh it's not going to do that
trick for binary outcomes so so that's
one reason why you might favor using b 2
um and we're just going to model it like
a linear regression the syntax is
essentially the same we can pass it a
data frame in this case Runners one has
been the data we've been working with up
to this point where we just have our
prior race variable and our variable for
whether or not Runners are wearing the
hypers shoe and we can get predictions
for our outcome Marathon running
times now sometimes we'd like to make
predictions for future data so there is
an argument keep trees its default is
false if you want to make predictions to
data that you do not have yet you're
going to want to flip that to true there
is a predict method you can use the
predict function and pass it new data
but only if keep trees is set to true
now some might ask well why would you
make the default false so when you save
all the trees it takes much more memory
and it takes much more
space now if you already have a data set
that you want to like say a test data
set available and you're just trying to
see how it perform out of sample there
are ways to do that without using keep
trees but if you want to use this stuff
to make predictions on data you don't
have yet and you're training a model
that you would like to maybe deploy for
other things you're going to want to set
keep trees to True uh one of the
problems of of scaling this stuff is
like I said it is very memory intensive
and that is why um the default for this
is going to be
false
so if we want to get predictions from
our training set if keep trees is set to
true we can just use this predict
function um and actually this is going
to be the test set here um I said
training but we want to do test you can
use this for training or test sets um
now there's an argument for type so
we're going to pass it our model in this
case fit one we're going to pass it if
we want to make new predictions it's
going to be new data and we're just
going to pass it our new data set if we
leave that blank it's just going to give
us our training set predictions now we
have a choice to make for the type of
predictions we want now in Bas in
statistics we get predictions from
What's called the posterior predictive
distribution or you get the expected
value uh my advice would be for just
general predictions particularly if
youve not seen uh if you're trying to
use this to make predictions for data
that you haven't seen yet uh you want to
use the posterior predictive
distribution what's that doing is just
adding in more uncertainty um and it's
the fact that we might um there's more
uncertainty about predicting things we
haven't seen yet and it's going to
account for that and it's going to make
our predictions less confident um now if
we look at what our predictions are if
we did this in a linear regression or a
gradient boosted machine we just have a
vector of predictions so that's not what
we have here uh we're actually going to
get a
matrix now what's going on so we have
800 runners in this data set and we have
an 800x 2000
Matrix what's the 2,000 so remember how
I talked about how we're going to
iterate again and again and again and
we're going to fit 75 trees and we're
going to fit 75 more trees and we're
going to keep keep keep fitting trees
we're going to do that about 2,000 times
now this has already removed that kind
of warm-up step in fact we've done it
more than 2,000 times but it is already
removed that in default cuz we don't
want to use those we know that they're
we know that it's not ready to be used
yet so these are all of the different
iterations we have and we're going to
use this is the information using to
make those kind of prediction
bands each in this case we have 2,000
rows and 800 columns and our columns are
going to be our individuals and our rows
are going to be our iterations so each
row of our Matrix here is a different
prediction from a different
iteration whereas each column is a
different individual in our data set and
we can use this to do a variety of
things so let's say if we just wanted
the point prediction have we we just
wanted our best prediction for each
person well we could just take the means
over the columns remember we have 800
columns those are individuals if we
average over we now have a prediction
for each individual now we just have a
vector of 800 after we average over the
columns and so if we wanted the
prediction for Runner 10 we can just
look at our Point prediction we can look
at the 10th individual in this vector
and so that our prediction is about 292
minutes and so these are the tools you
can use to extract an individual's
prediction when you just want the best
prediction you're less interested in say
what's the range of these predictions
what range can these predictions take
on we could also as I said it's a
distribution I think when we look at the
line bands it can be a little bit
misleading of the actual probability
Mass um and so we can look at the range
of predictions for Runner 10 and as we
see the mean is right in the center of
this prediction it is our best
prediction it's the best prediction we
can do but there's a whole range it
could be as low as 24 40 or as high as
340 and the nice thing about doing the C
aasian framework is we can interpret
this how how our Common Sense would
dictate we can say that there is a a
probability of a certain amount that our
prediction is going to be in this range
um we're avoiding some of the more um
we're not really thinking about null
hypothesis we're making direct
probabilistic statements
um now we can get we can we can we can
easily use just built-in R functions
like quantile to look at the r say a 95%
credible interval we can easily
calculate a 95% credible interval again
for Runner 10 and we can say well we're
we're 95% confident I mean this in we're
we're 95% confident that our prediction
for this Runner is between 267 and
317 so I talked about tuning the
means even though we're going to get
pretty good performance for these
continuous predictions right out of the
box what if we actually want to tweak
this K value so there is a built-in
function into the darts package called
xart and expart is what we're going to
use to tune some parameters we can just
give it a grid of parameters for what we
want to tune and it's going to do the
cross validation for us it's going to do
um I think the default it's a little bit
dependent on how big your data is and
for with 800 it did 21 fold cross
validation and so we can set up a grid
for k um to save time I kind of dialed
it back I started with uh 1 to 5 and I
change it to four to five because I
already know what the best answer is in
practice I would start at one and maybe
go up to five maybe um as I said the
default is going to be two but in this
data set our our best value of K is
actually going to be
4.9 um K can be kind of high sometimes
um like I said it depends on your data
the difference between are kind of
offthe shelf version of this version
isn't too big um but it's a little bit
better and so we can run this xart it's
going to spit out a matrix um we can
just average over all of it and see what
our minimum K value is or see what which
K value gives the lowest rmse in this
case it's going to default for
continuous variables to give you um
we're trying to get the lowest rmse for
continuous predictor um and so we see
that maybe our K is is is not what we
want to do um how do we refit B two with
a different K value so fortunately for
us this is pretty straightforward we can
just pass it there's an argument for K
it's going to default to two for
continuous variables but if we wanted to
change K we can just specify a different
number and we can use the built-in xart
function to let us know well what would
a better number
be you may also notice that I have this
verbose flag to false that's just for
the sake of these slides it's going to
spit out a bunch of information it's
going to tell you what all the priors
are it's going to give a count of how
many iterations you're at it's going to
give kind of a countdown of how much
longer is left in the modeling process
um so for the sake of these slides I've
set it to false um but you don't have to
think too much about what that parameter
is doing it's more of just a stylistic
thing again I'm keeping keep trees such
a true because I'm going to be making
some predictions uh out of
sample and so now um if we look at how
we performed uh strangely enough our
test set actually got better um we could
look at a um again the the label you can
see the uh labels a little bit off um
but we're still now even making even
better predictions the lowest we've seen
up until this point um predictions
around 11 um and and it's we're seeing
that estimating that uh perc of the time
to cross valid to the K is really
improving our predictions here
um and so that's just the basics of kind
of getting going with uh uh with using
the darts package for your own models um
but sometimes we want
to do different types of models that are
maybe a little bit more sophisticated um
some of you may have heard of partial
pooling now say that we have a factor
variable like country these are Runners
who are running a marathon we may track
what countries they're coming from in
big races like the Boston Marathon we
have people from all over the world
coming to run these things and so we can
extend the existing BK framework to
accommodate for things like partial
pooling so say we have this variable
country now it's possible that in our
training data we may only have people
from a limited number of countries and
we may want to make predictions in the
future and people may come from
countries we haven't seen before and so
in a traditional framework we'd be kind
of stuck like if we just model this as a
fixed factor factor and then say next
year we see somebody from country code
64 your model's not going to know what
to do um and now partial pooling instead
of treating each of these things as
fixed it's going to look at it as kind
of a population we're going to say well
there's some distribution of countries
we're going to model the variants
instead of the means um now so if you
wanted to just add a term and use this
in what it's called the full pooling
approach this is kind of the traditional
if we just put it as a predictor we just
add it to our just like a regression
we're just going to add a term for
country and fit everything else as we
have before now if we want to do
something a little bit more
sophisticated we're going to bring in
some heavier Machinery the stand for
Bart package the Standford Bart package
is built on top of darts it's using
darts to model the means nonlinearly
using Bart and it's using Stan to
actually uh parametrically model this
random effects term and so what I mean
by partial pooling is saybe want to fit
a random effect but want to have a
nonlinear mean we can do that with the
Stanford Bart package and it uses just
traditional lme4 style syntax and so we
can just put the terms that we want BART
to model in this kind of Bart section of
our call we have a stand for Bart
function we specify our outcome we're
going to say what we want to model
nonlinearly means and then we can pick
um using this kind of traditional one
bar uh random effects LMR syntax we can
say that we want to fit random
intercepts for
Country and this is going to give us a
partial pooling approach and so what
does partial pooling actually mean this
um for those of you who aren't familiar
well um it's going to improve our
um it's going to improve our predictions
uh it got cut off but the non-partial
pooling on the left is it giv us an RS
rmse of around 12.7 and with our partial
pulling we're down to 12.4 I should say
this is slightly different data I've
I've edited the example a little bit
that's why predictions are a little bit
higher this is a little bit harder to
model so why would we want to use this
thing well we can account for unseen
future groups um and we can make
predictions for some hypothetical unseen
country that we don't have um we could
uh account for non-id data we're making
this kind of Independence assumption um
what if we have inherently dependent
data like students nested within schools
and nested within classrooms we can
account for that nesting it's going to
further regularize our predictions um
which can improve our predictions and it
can be more efficient now all of this is
making some Independence assumption
about the relationship between the
random effect and the fixed effect um
beyond the scope of this talk but
there's a really good um summary of it
in Gman and Hill 2007 um
and the types of situations in which
this partial pooling is really really
effective is when we have a big
discrepancy in the size of our groups so
we have a ton of people from country
code 40 and one or two individuals from
say country 11 and so we had these big
discrepancies in the representation
across countries fixed effects May
overfit a little
bit and so I'm simulated some data to
give an illustration of what partial
pooling is actually doing so again this
black line is just if we just made a
prediction from the mean that would be
our prediction and these blue points are
if we made the traditional kind of fixed
effects approach we're just putting our
country term in as a predictor and some
of these terms are pretty extreme and
the size of each of these points is kind
of proportional to the representation
and so we see that some of the most
extreme points are actually these
relatively underrepresented cases and it
could be that because there's so few
people in there were kind of overfitting
them with the fixed effect
and so what a partial pooling solution
is doing is it's pulling in all of the
predictions to the general grand mean
and the amount of pole is proportional
to the size of the group so we see
individuals like this who are really
extreme and really small get regularized
a lot whereas even some moderately
extreme cases down here that are big are
getting regularized a little bit less so
our model is a little bit more hesitant
of underrepresented groups um
particularly when they have really
extreme predictions and again this fits
the the theme of this belief we have
that things should be pretty close to
the mean unless we have a lot of reason
to believe that they
aren't now how do we actually work with
these predictions um again with Stan for
Bart we can just run some simple line of
R code to extract the predictions um I
am wrapping up I know we're getting a
little bit over time um and so we can
just extract our predictions again we
have this 800 by 4,000 there's a few
more iterations built into the default
of stand for Bart generally a good thing
there's kind of more going on we want a
few more iterations to to get the
algorithm going you might notice this T
here because uh we like to keep things
complicated uh it's actually revers for
handf for Bart the rows and the columns
so I like to use this T just so
everything's all on the same page so we
have individuals in our columns and
iterations in our
rows now I'm going to jump over this
this is just some rcode I'll post these
slides so people can see how to extract
these things um we can write a whole
bunch of AR code to extract say
predictions for each country um and then
we can plot it so we can make plots of
each country's average running time so
we can average over countries and then
make statements about well which country
do we think is faster than the
other and then we can actually just
calculate the probability um so looking
in at say country 12 and Country 31 we
see that
tend to be probably the slowest
countries here um which one is which one
is slower um and so we actually know
that country 12 there's about an 83%
probability that it is slower than uh
country 31 and we're just dividing by
the number of
iterations um and so we can make some
statements these this is getting into
the inference space now where we can
actually make uh comparisons about
groups and put a probability on it
instead of just a point prediction for
each one and we're using the the wealth
of information we know about the
uncertainty of our
predictions and we can do the same thing
with individuals again just with a few
lines of R code we can calculate 95%
credible intervals and point estimates
um for all the individuals in our data
before we looking at countries now we're
just looking at
individuals now how is this stuff used
most in in my work and in the World At
Large Bart has remarkable uh uh uses for
causal inference it's a very very po
it's most popular uh application is in
the causal inference space um in the
causal inference space
and what is it well when we think about
a cause we really are thinking about two
potential outcomes in the case of the
hypers shoe now some of you been maybe
wondering can we actually say does the
hypers shoes cause people to run faster
if you've been kind of looking at these
images uh maybe it's hard to say now we
could think of what would have happened
to a runner what would have runner's
time been had they not worn hypers shoes
and we're going to call this y zero and
we could also ask well what WEA their
time would have been if they did wear
hypers shoes and we're going to call
that y one and the problem is we only
ever see one of those two things but
what we can do is we can turn this into
a prediction problem and we can say well
if we're missing a potential outcome for
each person what if we just make a model
and fill it in and that's the idea with
with Bart for causal inference is we're
trying to impute those missing
counterfactuals and if we have a
flexible enough model and if a few
structure things are true we can do it
um now B is not magic um and I don't
want to oversell it there's a lot of
work going on to continue to try to
improve it particularly and um uh and
and explore what is good at and what is
not good at but it is not going to work
for causal inference if uh we have
confounders that we haven't measured
we're making a really strong
ignorability assumption that well if we'
if we've collected all the confounders
and if we know what all those
confounders are we can model any
nonlinearities that exist we can pick up
any interactions in the data but we
can't fix what we don't have we can't
magically identify Compounders that we
haven't measured uh we're also making a
sitva assumption and an overlap
assumption again a little bit beyond the
scope of this talk but the short is
we're making some spill over thing we're
kind of saying that each treatment is
kind of affecting an individual
specifically and that say people who are
in the control aren't being affected by
people near them who were in the
treatment um and there overlap
assumption just saying we have
individuals that we can use to model um
we need
some people in the treatment group and
in the control group in the same part of
the covariant space now they don't have
to be weighted the same they can be we
can have a ton of people in the
treatment and very few people in the
control say at the lower end of our of
our um predictor but we need somebody
there and so if we go back to the very
beginning and we just fit a linear
aggression what would our causal effect
estimate be from from linear
aggression and you can look at the
coefficient and it's actually saying
that hypers shoes make you
slower now do we believe this or not I
don't know I mean maybe we could buy it
like if we fit a Bart model and there's
a specific package Bart cause that's
going to handle the causal inferences
pieces for you it's going to do all the
extraction we see that hypers shoes in
this case actually do cause you to run
faster but we would not have picked up
that effect if we relied on traditional
linear models to estimate them um now
this is just the tip of the iceberg um
in the space of causal inference Bart
has applications and saying well is the
treatment effect different across levels
of X um in this case looking at our
graph we certainly can see that it is
traditional models would have a harder
time estimating that um but because we
have all the added flexibility of Bart
and the inferential properties we can um
we can pick up nonlinear treatment
effects um but we can even still
estimate our average treatment effect uh
even when the data is highly uh
nonlinear um and so that's the talk for
today like I said just the tip of the
iceberg to all the things that are
possible with this algorithm um and
looking forward to Future conversations
around um how you can use it in your own
[Applause]
work all right I will kick this off with
a um a virtual question
then I'll see we have questions in the
room and we can go back and forth a
little bit depending what it is if
there's a question in the room please
repeat the question cuz they are not
miked up all right all right so
um in terms of of stand for Bart and
debart what benchmarks exist in case of
large data I'm going to say um so it
Stan for B is really slow it's really
slow um it's a big problem with it uh
Define what you mean by large data is
kind of the question like like how big
is is large um it's very new uh the
first paper on it was um actually just
published last year in entropy um and it
was specifically looking at the causal
inference space um so it's it's very
very fresh out of the box um so I don't
think a lot of benchmarks exist at this
time um but um how about debart itself
then darts yeah uh yes so darts again
most of the darts performances have been
really looked at um in the uh in the
causal inference World um so at the
American causal inference conference
there's a data competition and uh Bart
based models are annually um the top or
one of the top performers um and so what
they do is they have many many many
thousands of dgps um I think uh in 2016
where um there's a paper by uh Vince
Dory um Jennifer Hill Mark Scott and
others um where they basically look at
well in this competition we've got 7
7,700 kind of different data sets people
submitted different Sol Solutions which
ones did the best um that year Bart was
the top performer and it's essentially
what um the same uh kind of under the
hood things that became darts um so um
and there are some other algorithms um
that that um again like state-of-the-art
stuff that that performed very very well
too but every year um at AC it's it's
one of the top if not the top when you
say one of I just follow up for the
person and when you say one of the top
do you mean in terms of predictive power
or in terms of speed oh uh predictive
power it's it's relatively slow so so
Dart so like let's say darts compared to
HG boost which one would do better
predictive which one would do better
speed
um so I mean I feel I I don't want to
off the box say well this one's going to
be be better this one's going to be
other uh Bart's probably going to be
slower um uh darts is remarkably fast
compared to the older implementations
another reason to use it um one of the
reasons was created was to make it
aggressively parallelized um so the
initial implementation is much much
slower this one's taking advantage of
all the cores on your computer and is
doing it as efficiently as it can but
it's going to be slower than something
like like a great imp of machines cuz
there's just more things being modeled
and we have this this whole markof chain
money Carlo happening on the hood
computationally very intensive um so I
feel confident saying that darts is
definitely going to be slower than like
a gradient boosted tree but darts is is
um definitely faster than the older
implementations of Bart then I'm going
to do one more follow for this person
then I'm I guess I'm following up not
them um actually they are asking
aggressively paralyzes music to their
ears it's so aggressively paralyzable
can you do it on a GPU sort of like XG
boost goes on a GPU uh to my knowledge
no all right cool all right I'll turn
this over to a question in the room
we'll do a few room questions we'll go
back to Virtual go back and forth anyone
have a question in the room I have a
question um so you went over theti
Cooling and use as
a how does the model the
population yeah like repeat the question
repeat it oh yeah yeah yeah um so I
talked about partial pooling with
countries how does the model take into
account the population of each country
when fit in the model um so review of
multi models um again it's like like do
you do you mean taking into account in
terms of like how does it actually do
the partial pooling no like does it take
into account like if let's say one
country only has one yes that's exactly
what it's doing yeah yeah yeah so so
it's it's basically saying well there
may only be one person in this country
and so instead of just like what what a
fixed effect model is doing is it's
going to say well like the mean for this
group is the mean is this person's thing
and um that's our that's our effect so a
partial pooling is doing is at a high
level now the specifics of this I'm not
going to be able to answer in the Q&A
but um but at a high level it's saying
well if you are one of these
underrepresented uh countries um where
say there's only one you're the only
person from your country 10 the the
marathon it's going to pull your score
closer to the mean of everyone um and
you're going to get pulled more than
people that are from really represented
countries so if you're from a country
that's really well represented like like
say Kenya for example this is an actual
example um where there's there's a fair
amount of Kenyans running the marathons
and they all do remarkably well um uh
like I think last week actually the
world record was set was by uh by a
Kenyan uh runner I think they ran 2
hours and like 30 seconds which is
remark fast um like faster than I could
run a mile for for
26.2 um I think it's like like 46 split
like like crazy speed um but so uh if
you have a lot of people in my country
that are really extreme it's not going
to pull you that much because it's like
well we have a lot of cases like it's
it's it's it's something going on here
whereas if you're just one person um
could be a lot of things going on so
you're going to get regularized more
M
yeah
do you have another in room one we do
another one in the room before I go back
to
Virtual yeah so one thing you said a
little bit earlier was when you were
comparing debars
to um sort of like cross validated grid
searches yeah you did sort of say that
you sort of ined that darts would be
faster than doing the sort of cross
validated grid searches my question
really sort of follows from that it's
like how sensitive is Burman time and
model flexibility to the specification
of the priors yeah um repeat the
question that is a good question so
we're so good to repeat it oh yes um so
the question is how does uh burn in time
um factor into the specification of the
bottel um so in the case of and to get a
little bit into the weeds um if if you
look into things like convergence bar
models actually like don't have great
convergence in terms of things like like
uh like the mark set up by like the
stand development team um like they they
they have no mixing issues um in the
case of just like normal um
darts the like it seems to converge
pretty quickly um but but the normal
darts are still fitting relatively quick
like it's one of those things like it's
slow if you're doing a simulation study
and you're doing like thousands of these
things it's certainly slower than
regression but a single model will take
like a second or two um so it's not um
and and it'll scale some with the size
of data you're using um the stand for B
is much much slower because there's just
more going on there's like an HMC step
and a non HMC step and so it's the stand
part makes it really slow um and the I
think stand for Bart is a little and
there's some exploratory stuff that I'm
doing related to this right now the
stand for Bart um is a little bit more
sensitive to like like uh iterations and
burnning and things like that um but the
darts one is is is pretty quick off the
shelf do I going to follow up sure do
you run multiple chains and then check
for convergence yes yeah yeah yeah and
for for people who know more about these
things you um that the default is four
chains for darts um um like I for
Stanford Bart I usually run 10 chains if
you're doing Stanford Bart you want to
do more um um and and Bart cause
actually does 10 chains too um the
default for Just Darts prediction is
four though so it's kind of
automatically doing multiple chains
there's a built-in plotting function if
you want to plot chain convergence um
M yeah but you can see that if you check
the conver it settles down pretty
quickly to follow up on you is darts
itself using Stan also to to so what's
doing the Gib sampling in the HMC it's a
sampler there's no HMC in darts darts is
a it's a metropolis Hastings and um
within a Gib sampler um so it's a
metropolis Hastings for proposing new
trees um and the whole things R is like
C++ or is that in C++ so it's all in C++
um Barts is is mainly written in C++ um
and it's like the r interface to the C++
Bart cause is fully written in R and
it's like the wrapper for darts for
doing the causal inference stuff because
there's there's a lot going on for the
causal inference about like what gets
modeled Which Way um like for the things
we see we use the things we see for the
things we can't see we need to make
predictions it's it's default doing kind
of what you would want it to do in terms
of like one should use the posterior
predictive distribution when should you
do that um also plug there's a point and
click interface for Bart cause called
think cause
um whole different thing but if you
don't want to use r at all you can use
point and click and then CLE cool and
what's that written in what what's that
written in think CLE uh R and shiny nice
nice yeah so it's the the lowlevel C++
um Stan for Bart is is is using Stan and
using darts and they're kind of good
Stan for Bart
um yeah then we got a virtual question
um I thought original Bart paper the
original Bart paper terminal nodes are
deterministic average of observations in
that portion of the tree I think you
mentioned terminal nodes are normally
distributed can you clarify yeah can you
repeat that Sor I didn't catch up do
want me to I'm on the mic oh so I'm to
repeat for you yeah for me I didn't hear
the question it might be easier if you
read it yeah that's a really involved
question um okay let's see um
whoopsie you me to go back to it I hit
the wrong thing um let's see uh I
thought the original Bart terminal nodes
are deterministic average of the
observations in that partition of the
tree I think you mentioned terminal
nodes are normally distributed can you
clarify um the so yes the terminal nodes
are deterministic um but in um like when
they're being sampled like like the
likelihood um uh has has a a goian okay
and the eror the eror is definitely the
gausian part so when you add in the air
you're getting um like if you're using
the posterior distribution and bring in
the error that has like a linear
aggression is is a deterministic mean
but it is still normally distributed
yeah okay question in the room before I
any more
virtual a good choice for time
series um is repeat I the question is is
it a good choice sorry the question is
is it a good choice for time series um I
have not done any time series with it
and I have not seen anybody who has so I
don't want to say that hasn't been done
but I suspect no um there's profit which
is like a Basi and time series modeling
um that you could look into if you're
interested in basian Time series models
um I think their documentation is pretty
good
umh yep I have a question so to use the
package is there any Prive packages you
need to yeah so um uh it's it's it can
be uh question is are there PR are there
prerequisite are there prerequisite
installations for um if you want to use
darts or Stanford Bart um so you're
installing dbo should install a bunch of
stuff for you and if you if you install
it it should try to install the pr Rex
for you um you may have challenges with
the G4 Tran compiler um now there's some
documentation on GitHub uh that links
you to how to do it I when I've
downloaded R sometimes I've like like
when I got a new computer um and I
downloaded it it um worked pretty
seamlessly then there was another time
on a different computer where the G4 TR
took the whole process um if there are
any issues it's probably the G4 Trend
compiler in that I've had more issues
with stand for Bart than darts um but it
will attempt to um I would check the
GitHub page and there's a there's a good
um description of of the installation
requirements
yeah yeah one question over there you
mentioned in the St routine that it does
HMC stud
andc that yeah so it's all in a big Gib
sampler um there's basically it goes
back from like a stand step so so in
Stanford B whole different talk um that
I'm talking about at the DCR conference
and the question too the question was uh
um I'm getting better at this was okay
so so how can you have this thing where
there's like a stand step and a Bart
step because stand's an HMC and I said
Bart's a Gib sampler which it is and so
what's going on so it's all the Gibb
sampler but in in the different steps
there um there's a stand step where it's
it's modeling um the variance and Bart's
getting the mean so so Bart is doing the
non-parametric mean and then Stan is
doing the variance conditional on the
mean and then then then Barts meet is
condition on the variance and so it's
kind of back and forth um it's why it's
really slow there's a whole the the
stand part makes it makes it um makes it
slower um uh but yeah it's a cool it's a
cool algorithm and it's explained in the
paper too
follow that there's like you know four
chains where per iteration going back
and forth yeah so there is um like I I
did some the when when you do these
extract steps it cleans some things up
for you it's it's it's really a
three-dimensional array where it's
chains by iterations by people or
individuals I should say um and so you
basically have independent chains that
are going um and so you can check chain
convergence and like that and you and
for Stanford bar in particular if you're
using it you definitely want to do 10
chains um um and check the convergence
because there is a parametric piece
there too and and so you um
yeah um then you uh is there do you know
if there's a tidy models
interface I believe there is yeah there
is for for Bart yeah you can even pick
darts as the engine in the Tian models
ecosystem oh that's awesome yeah so if
you're a tidy modeler there is a and um
I checked it actually and it is there
yeah mhm nice cool so question over
there I see hand no and then I'll
question was was there tidy models I
miked at least so okay yeah so they can
hear me so I'm trying to be very quiet
over here um you talked about tuning
over uh the max depth of a tree or the
depth of a tree what about actually the
number of trees is that a yeah yeah so
so CGM talks about in the initial paper
too you can tune it too you can tune the
number of trees and you can use xart to
do it um like generally and and the
number of trees can change the results
if you want it to be a little bit more
flexible adding more trees can can make
a little bit flexible um a little bit
more flexible like if you're there there
have been some times and in my work
where I've explored adding more trees
when things weren't going well um but
uh it's I think generally this is big
caveat on generally um tuning the node
sensitivity prior that that K prior um
on the means is is the most influential
um
mhm because cuz you're doing a ton of
trees and we doing like 2,000 ultimately
so like well you're doing 2,000
iterations um yeah and again so cjm
talks about it too that like you could
there's a way where you could make it
like fully basian and and the trees
would be like the number of trees would
also be um uh calibrated and modeled but
it computationally just becomes too
crazy um they pick 200 uh the debart
implementation does 75 there have been
like there's some stuff that like says
that lower is good some stuff say higher
is good it depends on your use case um
like I said generally like there's like
the work like CGM showed and other
benchmarks have showed that it's it's
pretty good out of the box but um that's
another thing you can cross validate too
if you're really trying to maximize
performance
okay more questions in the room I have
one more question um is there like a
summary
of uh yeah so so oh yeah so is there is
there a summary of all the
coefficients um no not in like a linear
regression sense um in Stan for Bart you
can get that but I would not recommend
looking at those
coefficients um that'll give you a
warning T saying not to um we're doing
some work right now uh basically saying
like well you could add linear terms too
like not as random effects you could add
them as the linear term and then like
have that be your Baseline mean and then
have the BART part clean clean up the
nonlinear part around that mean there
may be some computational benefits and
some convergence benefits some work
that's going on now no definitive answer
um but you don't want to look at the
coefficients if that's the case because
they're non-identifiable uh what you
could do though is um you can basically
look at and and I skipped through it
because I was I was already going way
way over but you can um you have your
posterior distribution you can cut it by
values of a variable like I did with
Country and that's not a coefficient per
se but it's um you can basically get uh
estimates conditional on um yes so you
can say like well the the average
prediction of this country is this with
uncertainty this so you can do that
different than a coefficient and with
continuous variables you can do some
some binning um and there's some some
continuous plots you can do too so you
you look at visualizations but it's it's
not like a the traditional um
coefficient mhm thank
yeah I think there's another virtual
question are you going to be can you
share the code that generated the slides
or the walk yes yeah yeah yeah I did it
all on sharing again um I'll I'll uh
upload the code and that's why I had a
whole bunch of code Snippets too so
people want to explore it I encourage
you to do so and and you can use the
code that I provided here good yeah MH
um anyone else in the room before we
call
it nope okay well then a big round of
applause thank you very much for
speaking
so just a reminder we have the RGV
conference where you could hear yet out
a followup on this the third talk in
just a few months yeah um November 14th
at myyu I I got an email someone there a
bright light someone is volunteering to
speak but you know we need make sure
that works out um and also we're going
to go to the bar whoever wants to come
whether you drink or you don't drink if
you come to the bar you don't have to
drink but come hang out socialize we're
going to go to the Arts and Crafts bar
right around the corner from here and
that is everything so everyone please
have a good night and we'll hopefully
see you next month bye
everybody